there are stunts on this movie that you
could not get me to do but there are
some stunts he did do the spider-man
actors have had to execute scenes that
resulted in partial drowning collapsing
actors performers being sent through
literal fire coming at you are 20 of the
most dangerous scenes to film in the
spider-man movies
number one more stunts no problem
i want to do the action because that's
fun for me if defoe was going to return
and fulfill one of the longest options
sony has carried out in recent history
he was going in full tilt in the first
movie he did most of his stunts but the
producers figured being in his mid-60s
might make the actor want to pass on the
action in no way home but they weren't
getting to foe unless he was facing
danger to do this physical stuff was
important to me number two ever fight
till you can't fight no more
in my fight scene with the goblin
like i bust my hand up i like my
knuckles were bloodied and and you know
we were really going through this
high-risk battle was shot over about
four days leaving the actors in rough
condition i remember on the last day of
shooting that fight scene when john said
cut
willem and i both just collapsed to the
floor
and just because we were exhausted
number three
we're getting a bit too close for
comfort i don't wish on my worst enemy
just because they're close doesn't mean
they necessarily wanted to take on major
dangerous stunts altogether and it was
quite scary but of course that's what
happened in no way home we were all like
attached to each other you were like
sort of sitting on my lap and then jacob
was hugging both of us at least the trio
could trust they all had each other's
backs
number four
mj did say don't text and swing there is
one thing we got to do it was like um
this big kind of spidey swing through
new york no doubt zendaya was holding on
as tight as humanly possible they like
lifted us like i want to say like 110
feet
it was a big swing even though they used
reshoot footage from a much safer
situation it was still quite the
experience
and we did it and it was amazing and i'm
proud of myself for doing number five
stuntman take the wheel this whole
stolen car contraption was intense for
the young actor to take on safety was
key
and a stun here sits in that little
cabin terrifying as it was holland
luckily shot the car sequence without
being injured though they did crash into
a curb in one take so far
number six zendaya was right to worry i
get scared all the time like what if
he's working so hard that he throws up
luckily there was no vomit in sight but
i think they could drown in the suit in
the first one though yeah that's not
that much better i was laying face down
and i was really like stuck under that
thing like they would lower it down so
as scary as concrete weighing down on
you is it gets much worse because of
burst water pipes and obviously in the
mask as it got wet the water just kind
of built up in the front
and i was kind of like waterboarding
myself so i i had to rip them off number
seven there are no bonuses for this
risky stunt
tom was regularly facing danger but
nothing quite as intense as his stunt
double was diving straight into a lake
under a helicopter toby had wanted to do
it himself but after witnessing the
scariest thing i've ever seen it was a
hard pass i don't get paid enough for
this yeah that's fair number eight is it
still skateboarding if the board doesn't
touch the ground skateboarding can be
dangerous as is but now you want to
throw a wire work into that combo how
was he doing that yeah garfield had his
work cut out for him number nine
this could definitely be one of the most
romantic kisses of all time except for
the fact that toby maguire was low-key
drowning throughout when we did do the
upside down kiss he had given me a book
of like famous kisses romantic short but
not pleasant i would have to
suck air out of the side of my mouth in
the middle of kissing her and it was
it was really tough actually it was very
challenging love is a dangerous game
toby
number 10.
feeling a little warm toby sure cgi is
great but how about running in and out
of an actual burning building it's scary
when you send an actor into a burning
building i mean the first thought that
crosses your mind is
i hope that cg version of them is pretty
good there were literally oxygen
canisters used to make the fiery flames
really rage there's a little bit of
sparks coming out with the doors toby
dove into the fire himself and very
luckily escaped totally unharmed sure
there were crew members helping to
control it but still burning buildings
are never really safe
number 11. starting level dangerously
tough now as if flipping isn't
nerve-wracking enough as it is try doing
it off of a high up ledge if anything
had gone wrong his head was only
millimeters away from serious damage all
in a day of work as spider-man
number 12 is grant curtis a producer or
a surprise stunt person no doubt he
didn't anticipate this when he agreed to
do the role of a guard
i was standing there in a 600 pound sand
fist came crashing through the roof
producers don't typically volunteer to
be buried in sand but hey there's a
first for everything i think it was
three thousand pounds it dumped on it
number thirteen whose ramp
it's been used in films for decades the
casual ramp that launches a performer
when they step on it yeah totally chill
and not freaky whatsoever oh yeah we
should mention they were being launched
into a balcony
number 14.
how do you make a fight even more
dangerous take it to the sky there's a
great kind of air joust and whatever you
want to call it it was risky
so suddenly we're dealing with you know
very complicated very tough aerial shots
where you know we're seeing the actors
not having masks on meant toby and james
had to take the reins on this one
number 15.
is sending performers through fire
normal
today we're on stage 29 at sony shooting
a fireball element
going through it and that's exactly what
they did the wire work itself post
bursting through a fireball is no walk
in the park either number 16 who's ready
for bungee jumping
65 feet in the air toby's stunt double
had a major leap ahead of him for this
one just to do that drop we use three
winches that translates his weight so he
actually alters where he's hanging from
and and yes everyone was impressed even
spider-man toby as soon as we shot it he
looked at me and he goes that may be the
best stun in all these movies number 17
is this supposed to be a carnival ride
basically it can go 360 degrees
depending on how and where the car is
rigged dunst didn't leave all the risky
shots to toby the actress dove into
danger without hesitation it wasn't
really scary as more nauseating as when
they turned the taxi around yeah no
kidding while the fear factor wasn't too
high for mj it was still far from
pleasant number 18.
sorry you said 50 feet in the air i i
could die i mean really i'm not saying
that i ever feel like i'm in that kind
of jeopardy but if if somebody did the
wrong thing it is a possibility just
like holland and zendaya mcguire and
dunce held on to each other for some of
their more dangerous stunts
computer-operated machine had some kind
of weird glitch and decided to drop me
that would be really a disaster
fortunately there were no disasters on
this set number 19.
it's not really a stunt if you think
about it
alfred molina won't do any stunts unless
he really has to that's dangerous stuff
you know it's it's that's why they have
stuntmen you know because
otherwise we'd all be here throwing
ourselves off tall buildings while he
was resistant to it sometimes the team
managed to trick him into performing a
dangerous scene including this scary
train moment
is my hair on fire dude has good reason
to be worried number 20. who said a
senior citizen can't do stunts rosemary
harris did a lot of stunts too
she played peter pan when she was young
and that youthful spirit prompted
rosemary harris to insist she did her
own big stunts even though it wasn't the
safest choice since she was in her 70s
the production team of course had their
reservations but i begged them to and
they relented and it was lovely i loved
it facing danger is just another day in
the life for the spider-man crew and boy
do they earn those paychecks with these
risky scenes
which scene do you think would be most
terrifying to film